television and film writers are on the
picket lines for the second day this
morning they're demanding higher wages
and better working conditions the stakes
are huge for the future of entertainment
and many shows have already been knocked
off the air our Elise Preston is in Los
Angeles covering this story for us now
and joins us so Elise day one we saw the
late night programs immediately impacted
because we know I mean they're writing
to day of events and so that means
they're not prepared to go to air
um we saw reruns last night
and uh the late night shows were the
first to go dark we'll continue also to
see more shows go dark CBS is the talk
like many daytime programs will also not
be airing
um currently as far as uh new
programming but keep in mind Emery that
this in general so much of this strike
is because of how content and how we
consume content has shifted in the years
so much of this strike is about
streaming and the residuals that Riders
are not getting because they'll write a
show it could be a hit once it airs on a
network but then there is no place
anymore for them to rerun like they had
in the past and so they're going to
streaming channels where writers are not
getting those High residual checks I've
I've heard I've heard and seen some
writers say that residual checks that
they've gotten as of late have been
about seven bucks as opposed to hundreds
of dollars also keep in mind that that
last time there was a strike was in 2007
it started in 2007 and because there
wasn't scripted TV that's where we saw a
rise of reality television like the
Kardashians which is a Powerhouse today
that family uh really cashed in on what
happened from that Rider strike and the
other difference here as opposed to 15
years ago is that so many shows have
already aired their final episode of the
season so we are not seeing shows being
canceled kind of in the middle of a
season like we did in 2007 where some
shows one of my favorites Of All Times
girlfriends never got a conclusion in
that final season so in all so much of
this is about how content has been
consumed in recent years and just a
shift in programming that's really
fascinating so I mean what you're laying
out to me is you know the possibility
that uh you know the studios and and
producers that they might not feel the
same level of pressure that they felt
you know in 2007 when we had the first
strike which lasted for a hundred days
um The Fallout was significant at least
for California a lot of money was lost
because it's not just about the
Productions it's about all the secondary
bids businesses that benefit from this
huge industry is there a possibility
that we could see you know the
government of California maybe stepping
in to help out
so the governor has said that he is very
concerned he has said that he will
intervene if both sides uh have agreed
to that if both sides have asked that as
far as Mayors both here in New York and
Los Angeles those Mayors have said that
uh this Rider strike that writers are
vital to not only our culture but our
economy but it does not appear that the
Mayors are stepping in just yet you
spoke about that economic impact that
2007 writers strike had a roughly two
billion dollar impact in in loss of
wages here in in California alone and so
when you talk about other people who are
affected there are about 11 500 writers
in this Guild Anne-Marie but there's
makeup artists there's Caterers there
are a lot of people who are part of that
support staff as well when we talk about
production now some shows will continue
uh in production if the scripts have
been written but others are just on hold
for now you know and what you described
to me when we talk about at least the
dissatisfaction with with how they're
getting paid is something that would
require a major overhaul like either
they get more money you know from
residuals or they get more money up
front for writing whatever they're
writing right so this seems it seems
like the two sides are a long way off
what is the ideal solution
it does appear like they are a long way
off and by a lot of experts are saying
by all indicators that this strike could
last anywhere from six months to a year
which will push back production uh quite
a bit and they are far off another
indicator there is that uh these talks
did not go up until that deadline they
stopped hours before the writer's Guild
released a kind of a comprehensive side
by side of what they were asking for and
what the studios were offering I have to
tell you Anne-Marie when you go down the
list the writers wanted higher pay up
front they wanted higher pay
on the back end with residuals it looks
like the studios are willing to be
flexible there but then there are a lot
of other issues where there were not
counter offers presented one of which is
the use of Technology AI platforms can
write scripts in seconds and writers
want guilds or writers want limits on
the use of technology according to what
they released yesterday it does not
appear that there was a counter offer
there sent back by the studios oh that's
that's a whole other ball of wax right
there Elise thank you very much